[Música]
el lonje lo hello
hace tiempo trabajaba en una empresa y
había una recepcionista
yo llego a todos los días saludando como
creo todos saludamos
hasta que un día me freno
y me dijo bueno pp
y tú por qué vienes feliz todos los días
nadie me haya cuestionado eso nunca ni
yo y sin pensar lo primero que le
contesté fue
porque yo decido ser feliz problemas
tengo un chorro
me seguí llegué mi lugar y a partir de
ese día empecé a analizar el por qué yo
decidí a ser feliz todos los días me di
cuenta que ha sido un proceso que no es
fácil no es como que les voy a decir a
todos ustedes ahorita les voy a dar un
chip y a partir de hoy en este momento
todos van a ser felices y mañana sonríen
mañana despiertan con una sonrisa de
oreja a oreja no señores no es fácil ser
feliz hay que disfrutar
y yo he pasado por varios procesos por
varios pasos que es lo que me ha
funcionado a mí y es por eso que estoy
ahorita aquí porque se los quiero
compartir y ojalá puedan tomar lo que
les para servir a ustedes
para mí el primer paso
es que tienes que aceptar
cual eres físicamente emocionalmente
psicológicamente qq
y como eres con los demás
cuando yo estaba en la secundaria
era un niño normal empecé a comer de más
no hacía ejercicio empecé a engordar
bien rico ya había una niña que me
gustaba y por ahí me enteré que ese niña
dijo yo con pepe no ve anda porque está
gordito
bueno
me quise poner las pilas y en lo que fue
el de la secundaria la prepa empieza a
ser un chorro ejercicio la alimentación
pues dije esto no va a comer porque pues
esto engorda y pues me está costando el
bajar y quiero estoy bajando el peso y
me quiero bajar y bajar y bajar
y hacía mucho ejercicio y empecé a bajar
de peso empecé a marcar todo y había
cosas bien ricas que decían no esto no
lo va a comer porque esto me ha
engordado y yo me cueste un chorro bajar
entonces no quiero volver a subir
el problema aquí fue que no quería subir
ese de peso tiempo sea de empecé a
devolver el estómago para no engordar
nunca lo había hablado en público pero
yo decía no quiero no quiero acordar
comía y vomitaba caí en la bulimia
aunque no lo crean
pero si fue difícil porque estuve casi
tres años de la prepa ocultándolo
también mi mamá que anda por aquí no lo
sabía escuchando por primera vez sobre
mamá yo sé que me cocinado de corazón
pero
era el físico en ese momento
el tema de la bulimia lo va a dejar
aparte obviamente como pueden ver me
recupere tuve una combinación de bulimia
con alzheimer seguir comiendo
se me olvidó la otra parte y pues bueno
aquí estoy gracias adiós enterito y
feliz
el punto aquí es
yo no me aceptaba yo no me quería a mí
yo estaba haciendo algo por los demás
por quedar bien con alguien me estaba
haciendo daño a mí a mi cuerpo yo me
veía y me sentía gordo a pesar de estar
haciendo tanto ejercicio yo me sentaba y
me las lonjas eran cuadritos lo que
tenía aquí
y yo decía no no no es que estoy
engordando y devolvía el estómago pero
decir algo
y hago más ejercicio y la verdad digo
fue algo y el punto regresando a esto es
yo no me estaba aceptando a mí yo no
estaba aceptando quién era yo dejé de
hacer tantas cosas dejé de ir a la playa
dejé de ir a reuniones dejé de hacer
muchas cosas porque yo sentía que yo no
cuadraba o yo no quedaba en en ese punto
en esa reunión o algo porque yo estaba
gordito
por dios y ahorita soy un gordito
profesional
el punto es
que nadie estamos contentos con lo que
tenemos que porque tiene las piernas
largas que porque tiene las piernas
cortas que porque tenía celulitis que
porque tienes estrías que porque estás
muy peludo o porque estás muy lampiño no
tienes pelo y siempre le buscamos el
porque no nos queremos cuando en
realidad tenemos que aceptarnos y
disfrutar todos los días tal cual eres
johnny en las fotos quería salir
porque obviamente una que otra foto eitb
y así su bien
estoy bien gordo mejor yo tomo la foto y
yo empecé a tomar las fotos me sirvió
porque me di cuenta que me gusta la
fotografía
entonces como hobby después empecé de
que baje no pues tengo una técnica no
vamos a a
a tomar una foto podamos hacer unas el
fin entonces que hacía me pongo tres
cuartos sonrían
y salí a la mitad de mi carrera entonces
según yo ya no estaba tan gordo ni me
salía la panza por dios seguía igual de
gordo pero bueno ya empecé a salir en
las fotos y ahorita llamé una foto
grupal ya me paro ya soy él pero me
importa hacer eso si procuro no sé el de
al lado el del último porque si sale un
peor de lo que estoy no
así que señoras y señores hay que
aprender a aceptarnos ya querernos tal
cual somos como somos emocionalmente yo
soy muy llorón también de sentir de
sentimientos de todo hay que aceptarnos
y hay que esa parte si tú te bloqueas el
no querer ir a la playa
la gente paga ahorra todo el año para
venir un fin de semana a este destino oa
la baja o la pasó los cabos y mazatlán
puerto vallarta nosotros aquí lo tenemos
yo dejé de ir años a la playa teniéndolo
aquí y amo la playa amo el mar
y yo no lo hacía por no aceptar me
el ridículo no
ahora ya voy a la playa a gusto
me di cuenta que si voy y soy el gordito
de la playa a nadie le deshago el día
todo mundo sigue brincando tiroteando
tomándose la cerveza y jugando con los
niños y yo también aprendí a disfrutarlo
es lo mejor obviamente pues estoy
gordito me van a echar carrilla digo hay
que aceptar que estoy gordito o gordo
como el quién llama eso mi ya no me
afecta tan no me afecta que yo me dice
mis propias frases motivacionales así
con cajas quien se echa porras podemos
no salir tan entonces pues que dije pues
primera prefiero ser un gordito feliz
que un flaco amargado
así que obviamente ojo no promuevo la
gordura y que quede muy claro por favor
es difícil ser gordito la verdad hay que
buscar también estar lo más saludable
posible pero si es algo con lo que yo
estoy todos los días tengo que aprender
a vivir lo ya disfrutarlo y que eso no
me afecte en mi día
tengo otra frase cuando te dicen cómo
que aceptes tuvieran otra de las que
listo no pues si mi hijito pero lo gordo
se quita lo lo feo no
adelgazó si me ayudó un poquito
hecha por la solo
el segundo paso
no hay que esperar nada a cambio de los
demás
qué significa esto
una vez estaba en el comedor en casa de
mis papás echando pestes mis amigos se
habían hecho una reunión o hicieron algo
salieron no me acuerdo bien y no me
habían invitado
llega mi cuñado que en paz descanse
dice que tienes pp y una vez que éstos
salieron y no me invitaron y yo siempre
los invito y yo siempre paso por ellos y
yo siempre estoy siempre lo otro y ellos
o sea ni me hablan
debo decir algo nunca esperes nada a
cambio de los demás si no vas a sufrir
mucho en la vida a partir de ese momento
todo lo que hago lo hago de corazón si
ayudo a alguien ayudó porque yo quiero
si le doy un aventón a alguien luego
porque yo quiero y no soy esperando que
me regresen el raid
así que siempre hay que hacer todo de
corazón porque porque en el momento que
tú quieras esperar que ellos te lo
regrese vas a sufrir un chorro y vas a
decir es que yo le ayudé y a mí no me
ayudó no señores ustedes ayuden hágalo
de corazón y no esperen nada a cambio
eso se les va a multiplicar por personas
que menos se le esperan el día que menos
se le espera se los garantizo lo tengo
súper probado
no sabes en qué momento y ese día que
alguien te hace algo te regala o te dice
te ayuda lo que menos esperas es un día
mágico
te lo hacen especial ese día
el tercer punto que pasó perdón
es el no ya lo tengo fácil
quiero un aumento de sueldo no lo tenía
pero qué pasa si me dicen que sí
qué pasa si te gusta una niña un niño y
quieres andar con esa niña y llegas y le
dices oye me gustas
puede que te diga que sí
y si te dice que si hasta el amor de tu
vida puedes encontrar
yo hace más de 15 años
conseguí ese sí
hace exactamente 15 años a esta hora
estaba en el altar parado diciendo si
acepto
y tengo
15 años de feliz matrimonio con una
mujer espectacular que ha sido mi amiga
mi pareja mi cómplice y es de las
personas que me ayudan a ser feliz todos
los días
así que señoras y señores siempre hay
que luchar por ese sí porque no sabemos
hasta dónde vas a llegar no hay que
suponer la respuesta que te van a dar lo
único que pueden suponer es que él no ya
lo tenemos pero que pueden conseguir un
sí y si les dicen que no sigan
trabajando por ese sí si le dicen que no
al aumento sean mejores en su trabajo
vuelvan a buscarlo no se pongan tristes
que no les arruine su día porque porque
ya sabían que ese no ya lo tenían pero
pueden seguir luchando de manera
positiva con una sonrisa con una muy
buena actitud y seguir buscando esos sí
siempre
el cuarto paso
es una historia
igual de la prepa tenía un amigo que
otros amigos no lo aceptaban mucho
porque decían que es como que el loco
pero era mi amigo y la verdad muy buen
amigo y salíamos mucho hacíamos muchas
aventuras vencemos de la paz y salíamos
a la playa y todo
mucha gente no no lo aceptaba o no lo
quería o no lo recibía yo sí era mi
amigo pero si tenía una característica
que hasta que como amigo mío me hacía
ruido no tenía un sobre amor o no sé
cómo llamarlo algo que para mí no era
normal su relación de un chavo de 16 y 7
años con su familia le quiero mucho en
mente que te quiero hermanita te quiero
mucho sea su hermanita por dios es edad
no hay hablas hacia tus hermanos digo yo
sé que si los queremos y los amamos pero
a veces dices oye tenemos 16 7 años no
estamos haciendo pactos y como que
hables así delante la gente pues como
que no te apena
pues no y la verdad nunca se lo
cuestione a él lo serán cosas como qué
pensabas un día
llega mi mamá y me pregunta
oye pp
tú sabes
que la mamá de tu amigo tiene cáncer
me quedé las manos ha parado un chorro
de flash backs de todas las veces
de como él se acercaba con su familia
como los abrazaba como él no le daba
pena ni ridiculizarse ni nada en
decirles te amo te quiero besos abrazos
y por la otra parte
decía en la torre yo no he hecho nada de
eso
yo la palabra te quiero no la tengo en
mi vocabulario
me armó de valor
es momento
a mi mamá
haciendo escenas
así
y hago bien emocionado
y le digo el abrazo de un mamá
te quiero
la primera vez que lo dices
se te llena todo porque es lo estaba
diciendo
de corazón
y
esa parte
yo esperaba que voltear a mi mamá
se queda y me dice que quieres
y yo
mamá te quiero
quieres permiso
saben cómo me empecé a sentir
no mamá
te quiero
quieres dinero
y vamos a reconocer que si salías y
pedía dinero si pedía permiso y si
pasaba todo eso pero
le volví a decir se voltea mi mamá nos
vemos a los ojos y le vuelvo a decir a
la cara mamá
te quiero
recuerdo perfectamente cómo le cambió la
cara
y me dice yo también fueron los te
quieros fregones de corazón y es mi mamá
o sea obviamente me tenía que querer y
yo le tenía que querer lo importante es
que no lo decimos damos por hecho que
nos queremos y que me quieren y que los
quiero pero yo yo no lo decía la cara yo
no lo decían los ojos en ese momento
salgo
en la cochera veo a mi papá
me paró enfrente de él y le digo la cara
papá
te quiero
la reacción de él fue me dio un beso me
dijo yo también y me abrazo
pudiera pensar como recuerdo que es el
primer beso que mi papá me da la primera
vez que tenemos ese acercamiento y ha
sido de lo mejor que tenía en mi vida y
desde ahí me propuse aprender a decir te
quiero no aprender a decirlo de corazón
de decirlo a la cara de estar bien con
los demás porque yo no sé si yo voy a
estar mañana
yo no sé si ellos van a estar mañana
así que señoras y señores hay que
aprender a decir te quiero de corazón a
las personas que nos importan a las
personas que están a nuestro alrededor a
nuestros hijos a nuestros hermanos a
nuestros abuelos
así que recuerden
hay que aceptarnos como somos
no hay que esperar nada de los demás
hay que luchar por lo que queremos
y hay que hacerlo todo siempre con una
sonrisa y diciéndole te quiero a la
gente eso es lo que a pepe le ha
funcionado y es por eso que todos los
días decidido ser feliz gracias
[Aplausos]